[Musique]
aujourd'hui on nous chante gago à côté
des champs elysées où on va parler de la
maison connectée avec le lancement de
bosch smart home qui promet vraiment
d'être super rénovation pour la maison
connectée
[Musique]
oui
laurent tu nous accueillent ici dans un
vieux top pour effectivement présenté
une nouvelle solution pour la maison
connectée pour bosh est ce que tu peux
nous expliquer un petit peu quand vous
marchez solution avec plaisir bosch a
décidé de lancer une solution assez
homogène préconstruites de maison
connectée mais aussi très simple l'idée
c'est de à travers un ensemble cohérent
être capable de piloter tous les aspects
de la maison qu'on ait fait que ce soit
la sécurité l'économie d'énergie le
chauffage la vidéosurveillance tout ça
dans un ensemble on a la chance d'être
professionnel de la vidéo
professionnelle de l'électroménager du
chauffage donc de pouvoir apporter
toutes ces technologies aux
consommateurs de façon collective
[Musique]
m
on a vraiment de reproches en réalité ne
paul j'irai plus surveillance en règle
générale et le bol régulation de
chauffage économies d'énergie c'est
vraiment les deux grandes activités
qu'on pourra retrouver si j'élargis un
petit peu louis les interagissent parce
que l'idée qu'on a c'est que tous soient
interopérables
c'est qu'un évêque un élément du système
un accessoire du système n'est pas
qu'une fonction un détecteur qui va
permettre de vérifier si une porte ou
une fenêtre est ouverte va bien sûr un
grand rôle de sécurité d'affaires une
alerte intrusion mais veut aussi être
capable de baisser le chauffage sur
robinet thermostatique parce que aéré
échauffés en même temps c'est un peu
unique et par rapport aux pénétration du
marché vous ciblez j'imagine le grand
public
avec cette solution les yeux vous pensez
le grand public va s'équiper de quelle
manière sûre de la rénovation sur le
fait de se dire bah c'est quelque chose
qui est super quelquefois même permettre
de faire des économies d'énergie du coup
je me positionne sur ce produit je
l'achète même s'il ya à la base en
investissement comment est-ce que vous
fonctionnez qu'est-ce que vous avez un
peu comme prévisions le dessus alors la
première attente des gens aujourd'hui
c'est la sécurité c'est de sécuriser
leur domicile c'est pour ça que nos
produits héros sont par exemple des
caméras de surveillance intérieure en
respectant la vie privée aussi ce qui
est très important que les gens ils
veulent être assurés unis veulent pas
être est ce que dès qu'on m'a créé nos
caméras pour leur apporter cette
réassurance par exemple en escamotant
l'objectif quand on ne veut pas être
filmés
donc ça c'est évidemment un grand pilier
et c'est pour ça que les gens vont venir
et vielle aujourd'hui à la maison
connectée
mais ce qu'on veut nous c'est
aujourd'hui aussi leur expliquer que
simplement ça c'est vraiment une
tu évoquais sait on a vocation à
apporter quelque chose ça que n'importe
qui peut s'approprier avec des processus
d'installation simple les processus de
d'utilisation simple une application
super active pour que les gens puissent
tous facilement chez eux
aller plus loin que juste sécurisé on et
profiter d'économies d'énergie qu'il
évoquait mais aussi se sacrifier la vie
et simplifier la vie qu'est ce que ça
veut dire ça veut dire plus de temps
pour soi travailler à l'esprit plus
libre ou en profiter pour faire autre
chose
[Musique]
par par rapport à l'économie quelqu'un
qui par exemple va rencontrer dans des
travaux va changer les installations
on est quand même sur un quai quand même
un petit peu élevé si je le mets qui
paie par exemple sur une fouille
complète sur de la sécurité sur des
chauffages machines permet peut-être
pour un jour à dire une bêtise où il ya
les fascinantes et sur un ensemble de
vote aux réunions dont une solution
globale
dis-moi s'ajouteront non non c'est lors
de tout dépend d'eux à quel point on
veut aller
la configuration de la maison etc
moi je trouve que j'habite une maison qu
à trois niveaux mais l'accès se fait
uniquement par rez-de-chaussée il faut
être
alpiniste pas vara pistes pour pour
accéder aux seconds
si je surveille le rez-de-chaussée je
surveille d'accès à la maison à paris en
plus d'un côté jeune homme sur une rue
dont j'ai vraiment une porte d'entrée
une fenêtre à surveiller mois avec un
système de sécurité de base à moins de
500 euros
j'assure la prévention anti intrusion et
la prévention la surveillance anti
incendie de ma maison si je rajoute une
caméra derrière je suis sur quelque
chose qui vous pas 750 euros et j'ai une
vraie sécurisation de mouret de chaussée
donc de ma maison
si j'avais un manoir dans le berry ça
serait une autre paire de manches je
devrais je n'ai pas de manoirs relevé à
une valeur de tous d'accord donc il ya
ce point là lorsque tu dois tout à
l'heure de la représentation c'est que
vous travaillez en partenariat avec
collaboration avec les leafs
tout à fait notamment par rapport aux
ampoules eux collecté absolument si je
dis pas de bêtises dessous comment
est-ce que vous positionnez-vous ce
genre de collaboration est pareil est
effectivement de d2 sécurisé d'avoir
vraiment
vision globale sur la relation client
sur les données clients bien sûr ce qui
est super important proche c'est de
s'assurer que les données consommateurs
restent à compléter des consommateurs
parle de respect de la vie privée on met
en place des choses pour respecter les
néo conservateurs des consommateurs
pardon et tout ça ne va pas sans
sécurité donc on travaille les
partenariats de façon structurée avec
des industriels dont on pense qu'ils
sont comme nous les gens qui vont
respecter les données de leurs
consommateurs ne pas en faire n'importe
quoi sans leur consentement et aussi
technologiquement assurer cette sécurité
c'est pas tout de dire je ne ferai rien
t'es donné si les données sont trop
aisément qui est instable
évidemment vous annoncer rien et on
travaille en partenariat serré avec des
industriels te fais les choses comme le
partenaire conte avec philips france
offrira la chance d'avoir été parmi les
rats les industriels que philips a
sélectionné poitrine sociaux ce qui veut
dire qu'on avoue rémi votre partenariat
et d'intégration et ça nous permet comme
ça d'assurer des développements qui pour
d'autres consommateurs sont sécuriser au
maximum et ça c'est important
salut je fais une maison avec un beau
ciel d'alarmé je ne mange pas où
j'explique à tout le monde où il a pris
pour débrancher ses blagues ça c'est pas
d'adressé l'idée sur la donner ce qui
est ce qui nous paraissait intéressant
par rapport à ce qu'ils aient tout à
l'heure c'est que vous avez une
expertise effectivement déjà sur le fond
la domotique sur les caméras parce que
ça fait aussi partie de notre métier
mais aussi en sur le bail il trop
ménager ce qui fait que au final vous
maîtrisez la chaîne quasiment de a à z
que ce soit sur le chauffage parce que
vous faites effectivement des chaudières
que ce soit sur les quatre engagées sans
gestion et l'économie d'énergie
également ce à partir l'application pour
la programmation à distance
ça ça me paraît être intéressant c'est
l'idée de bosch marteau mais en fait on
a dans le groupe une activité
électroménagers sous les marques bosch
wimax iman notamment on a dans le groupe
une activité chauffage et des shows dias
ma gauche vln leblanc on a dans le
groupe des activités de
vidéosurveillance ont surveillé les
aéroports on surveille les villes de
france grâce à des caméras et donc
l'idée c'est de permettre d'intégrer
tout ça dans une seule et même
application tout à fait et ça restera au
fur et à mesure dès 2018
l'électroménager ou le connect sera
pilotable par nos systèmes aux pilotes
déjà des produits de philippe travaille
avec des mares de
de systèmes de sonorisation de
divertissement voir intégrer des
partenaires comme ça et créer un
véritable écosystème complet de la
maison on a effectivement la chance en
groupe d'avoir d'avoir trois quarts la
maison déjà on à l'électroménager on a
le chauffage on sait faire de la
domotique de la vidéosurveillance et des
choses qu'on va devoir aller chercher à
l'extérieur des partenariats qui vont
nous permettre de compléter on n'est pas
de chez n'y fit donc il en faudra que
oui bien sûr et tout ça va se construire
au fur et à mesure on a en plus les
compétences informatiques en gros on a
en plus notre propre cloud et ça on l'a
pas évoquée mais c'est super important
bosch a choisi d'avoir ses propres
serveurs en allemagne bosch pour loger
toutes ces applications et outils pour
s'assurer que les données qu'on collecte
qu'on garde pour les conseils les
consommateurs soient stockées de façon
sereine en europe dans un pays assez
rigoureux là dessus pour ne pas les voir
s'envoler pour la mettre en parallèle et
géographie qui sont plus légers
peut-être ce n'est pas à moi de faire ce
genre de parallèles alors est ce qu'on
peut dire qu'au final boss smart home
c'est un peu le sommet de la pyramide
c'est l'ombre du tous ou d'avant hier je
crois exactement le du [ __ ] convergent
et au final on est tous gérés exactement
vacances
sachant que chaque produit peut
conserver une application ultra pointue
et qu'une application ombre est la
vocation toujours à gérer le 80 pour
être simple ok je te remercie je t'en
prie merci à toi au plaisir j'espère que
tu étais une caméra mais alors pourquoi
est ce qu'on parle d'eux bosch smart
home
aujourd'hui le but de cette vidéo c'est
pas de faire une vidéo promotionnelle
pour la solution poche marteau par
contre ce qui est hyper intéressant
c'est qu'on voit que la maison connectée
c'est vraiment le truc qui est en train
de se développer
google apple bosch amazon énormément de
grosses grosses boîtes s'intéresse à
cette problématique nous apporter des
solutions au quotidien tout le monde va
y venir à plus ou moins long terme et on
va tous venir à la maison connectée
l'intérêt est effectivement d'aller
rencontrer bosch aujourd'hui par rapport
à cette problématique c'est que pour
sait très bien que bosch c1
normes industrielles ils l'ont dit dans
plein de solutions et quentin boîte
comme ça commence à s'intéresser à la
problématique de la maison connectée
on doit y aller pour essayer de
comprendre de voir comment est-ce que
prennent l'enjeu et comment est-ce
qu'ils vont la traiter cette
problématique
alors on voit qu'aujourd'hui il ya
encore plein de problèmes on en parlait
les problèmes de traitement de données
sa lettre est clairement de très grosses
boîtes qui certaines sont assez légères
en termes de données donc ça veut dire
de la gestion de la donnée personnelle
les risques liés effectivement pas aussi
au piratage de ces données les solutions
par rapport au chauffage et à toutes ces
problématiques la imagine je sais pas on
rentre du boulot on rentre du travail on
dit ben on est géolocalisé part de
téléphone on est à quelques mètres on
approche de la maison la maison commence
à chauffer on est à cinq mètres de la
maison
les lumières s'allument l'ambiance est
là c'est comme si on l'avait jamais
quitté le foyer toujours sympa pas la
peine d'arriver à lui mais toutes les
ampoules ans effectivement c'est des
gestes du quotidien qui ont des
complètement capable de faire mais en
imaginant que tout ça soit vraiment
facilité ça rentre même le quotidien
beaucoup plus agréable donc toute cette
problématique là est hyper intéressante
on va en parler régulièrement là c'était
vraiment un lancement fin avec
effectivement cette grosse grosse grosse
grosse première pour bosh en france je
me devais d'en parler on en parlera
régulièrement parade cette problématique
là qui est vraiment passionnante parce
qu'elle fait partie de notre quotidien
et l relier un petit peu toutes ces
problématiques de tous ces objets
connectés en ayant bien sûr au centre
tous à d'autres téléphones et notre
géolocalisation donc voila un petit peu
et je tiens vraiment réalisé que cette
vidéo n'a pas du tout était sponsorisé
est absolument aucun des financiers
entre bosch et moi ça je tenais à
préciser
merci d'avoir regardé cette vidéo dis
moi ce que tu penses a effectivement de
toute solution connectée est ce que tu
penses que cette solution là en tout cas
de paraît intéressante et est-ce que tu
envisages
à venir pourquoi pas d'investir et de
d'équipé mais moi tout ça en commentaire
on en reparle très bientôt si le contenu
te plaît n'hésite pas à ta bonnet est
effectivement abete un joli poussent
vers le haut merci et puis je te dis à
très bientôt
ciao
[Musique]